[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
charles barkley hall of famer turner
sports inside the nba and ncaa analyst
i'm thinking maybe you hosting the
oscars next year we don't have any
problems with anybody coming on stage
what do you think chuck
that would be a lot of pressure brother
to handle that situation
that'd be a lot of pressure
listen uh
i love chris rock i love with will smith
will was 100 wrong
let's just leave it right there
i don't want to pile on but i love chris
rock i love will smith but will smith
was 100 wrong
that's it
uh but you've had moments where somebody
says something to you when you played
yeah and i was wrong when i think i've
been arrested four or five times for
punching people and i was wrong
it's all right to meet you wrong dan i
was wrong i
i think seriously i think i've been
arrested four or five times i can't
remember off the top of my head
and i was wrong when i did it it was an
overreaction
part of our job is to get heckled
and people say stupid stuff to you but
at the time i was 25 26
and i was an idiot for overreacting
unless somebody physically come at you
grow up i'm almost 60 years old now
and stuff you do when you 25 26 when
somebody heckle you you can't do it that
goes with the job
yeah i know it's tough because i've been
courtside and i hear some of the things
that are said and i don't know how you
you just turn the other cheek
yeah listen unless they get personal you
just turn the other cheek i mean you got
to yeah i mean fans listen most of the
fans are great i've said this to you
before
ninety percent of fans agree
10 percent of them are just jackasses
who are jealous and ain't and just mad
at you because you're successful but you
got to turn the other cheek
who would have thought that we're seven
days out from the start of the masters
and there's a chance that tiger woods is
going to be playing
man
when i started following that
i'm not a nitwit i wasn't following the
plan and everything when i started
hearing their stuff uh it was exciting
um
i don't know if he can win
but it'd be fun to see him there
i mean i think just making the cut
i mean if he win it it'd be like the
greatest sports story ever
i mean it'd be crazy considering where
he was
but if he just makes the cut it'll be an
incredible story
i think even if he tees it up charles
even if he plays one round
yeah i mean i think he's gonna come back
and play at some point but i'm saying if
he was able to make the cut it'd be a
really cool story
how many times you played augusta
i have never played augusta i've had
actually you know it's so funny i i was
invited to play
one time when i was playing but i
couldn't make it work because one of my
my friends was a puss
so one of my friend's name is neil
hartman
and he was getting married
saturday night
at six o'clock
and i had a friend i was gonna rent a
private jet we were gonna fly to augusta
and play
and he was too much of a coward he's one
of my best friends he was too much of a
coward i said dude we're going to be
back like three four hours in advance
and we didn't get to play
and then i actually got an opportunity
to play next monday
but
the regular seasons ends on a monday
i talked to tony about it they already
told me to do it that's it too much so
the season ends next sunday
i was invited to play the following
monday but the play-in game starts on
tuesday
and i was like yo man i get off at two
in the morning
i'd have to leave at six tee it up
drive two hours
and then get back and do a game the next
day and i said i'm just going to wait
until like because i want to enjoy the
experience
so yeah i i'm supposed to play next
monday but i just can't make it work
it's charles barkley the hall of famer
inside the nba analyst um do you have an
mvp vote
i do not
do you want one
i don't care but let me tell you
something this is gonna be
you know i had embiid for 90
of the season
i think the joker has probably taken the
lead
i would love to see more love more love
for devon booker
but man it's gonna be really tight like
i say the first
five months of the season the embiid had
it
and he's kind of slowed down
joker has been consistent
but like i say i would love to see devon
booker get some more love in the
situation
is james harden hurting joel embiid's
mvp chances
you know i wasn't a big fan of the trade
when it happened
um
i think
it's either gonna go down take one of
the i mean the six has got a two-year
window to win it this year and next year
and that's it
uh it's gonna be really tight in the
eastern conference cause man
i actually watched boston play uh miami
last night
uh
i don't even think either one of those
teams are gonna win the east i still
think it's miami
excuse me excuse me i think it's
milwaukee i think milwaukee is still
going to win the east
hey listen
if somebody voted for giannis
antetokounmpo i would have no problem
with mvp either
but i do think it's well and joker and
devin booker should get some love but if
if john doesn't want it i would have no
problem with that but i think they're
the team to beat in the eastern
conference yeah i'm with you i thought
it was embiid's to lose but
you know i watch giannis and he's
competing against himself
what he does like we're kind of
measuring him against himself
and i think we're taking we take him for
granted
yeah i i don't know if we take him for
granted i mean they were struggling
early with because of all the injuries
and they're probably gonna i and uh i
think they're probably gonna finish with
the best record in the east
and if he like i say joel was playing at
a hell of a level before the james
harden trade
and you you consider he they had they
were in the top three or four without
ben simmons
but listen he has faded uh a little bit
uh but like i say uh joker has been
there and he's keep playing he's playing
at the same level
but like i said devin booker gets no
love and he deserves some love this is
going to be in my opinion probably the
closest
vote since i got robbed by magic johnson
in 1986-87
[Laughter]
i'm still bitter dan did you think you
got robbed
a hundred percent i got robbed
because if you go back it was uh it was
the closest vote ever
and what bothered me about it was
i got all the first place votes and i
didn't get any second and third place
votes which was impossible like wow
if i don't get
if i get all the first place votes the
worst i'm gonna get is second and third
so if you go back and look at the voting
i got all the first place votes and then
i didn't get any second and third place
vote and i was really pissed about that
okay did you get was it more of a
robbery that you didn't win or that shaq
lost to steve nash
well see shaq shaq is 100 wrong in his
argument it never and see this is like
it's like when these guys on television
today who have no talent
they they pull up they argue about the
michael jordan uh lebron
thing and it's like wait a minute
there's no right or wrong answer i'm a
michael guy and i love lebron lebron is
amazing but these guys on television who
have no talent
argue about stuff that's like so it's a
lose win proposition
so
i i shaq
it's always went to the guy who had the
best record in the nba it never went to
the best player michael jordan was
probably the best player in the nba for
three years before he won mvp because
his team wasn't winning
but this argument shaq the defending
sons had the best record in the nba
those years was shaq a better player to
steve nash
yes yes yes but
my phoenix sons had the best record in
the nba
and if you go back and look in the last
30 years
magic wasn't better than bird whoever
had the best record won mvp
uh uh same thing with kobe kobe probably
should have won a couple more mvps
because he was better but his team was
mediocre
so this fake argument they have every
year who should get mvp
joelle
joker
devin booker and janice it's got to be
one of those four guys if you vote for
somebody else you're just trying to pray
be contrary
who does joker remind you of
wow that's a great question dan you know
i don't know
because i don't know if we've ever had a
center who could shoot threes
he's probably the best passing center
ever
um
if he reminded me of somebody he's not
as big as him but probably it's a bonus
okay so bonus in his heyday was a great
three-point shooter he was probably the
best passing big man at the time
uh joker man to shoot threes his ability
to pass the ball
i don't know if we've ever had a guy
like him and the thing that the beauty
of his game is
you know we get so enamored with guys
who are athletic dan who
they they're very athletic but they
can't play dead i mean you look at the
nba now we got a lot of guys who can run
and jump but they can't play dead
but to be able to play as great as he is
and not really athletic it's it's a
testament to how great he really is
well i see it it's like when i first saw
luca when he was playing in europe and
he's playing against grown men
but it looked like he was just getting
by them he was just getting his shot off
but he was and i thought
god
i don't think he'll get away with that
in the nba i don't know if yeah
and but he does he just gets by you he
just gets his shot off but he's doing it
against the best players in the world
well he does stuff you know kawhi
leonard plays like that too
i mean he plays they just play at their
own pace joker plays at his own pace you
can never speed them up
they play they get where they want to go
and they make the play
that's a great example luca
luca's amazing but he plays at his own
pace he doesn't he doesn't look like
he's the most athletic athletic guy in
the world
neither does kawhi who's a great player
also but joker's the same way i think
all three of those guys are great but
they always play at their own pace
you never see them doing stuff like a
lot kawhi made a dunk in it
in the place last year everybody went
crazy because it was the first time we
saw him like really go crazy and dunk on
the whole team but other than that he
plays at a steady pace
how tough is it dealing with kenny smith
on the set with north carolina doing
well in the tournament
it's unbearable it's unbearable he's
just a pain in the ass that's the only
way i can explain it and the thing is
funny
he is worse way worse off camera than
like the other day the other day he put
his little coffee cup up and put his
feet up on the desk says oh this is a
cakewalk uh i'm i just need a cigarette
right now i mean he but he listen and i
don't mind it hey when aubry made it to
the final four i was going crazy because
i mean we had never been to the final
four
and uh it was it was one of the greatest
things in my life seeing auburn in the
final four it was cool
but but kenny is making people duke fans
there
that's that's hard to do
no you're either a carolina fan or
you're a duke fan like one of our bosses
uh sean
he's the biggest duke fan in the world
uh the big boss at cbs sean mcmanus yeah
sean mcmanus but he likes he walks
around and he comes in every a day and
talks about i really need us to get to
the final four he's and listen
that's the one thing i say then i've
been to the olympics twice it's the
greatest thing i've ever experienced but
there's nothing like march madness it's
the coolest event other than olympics
i've ever been part of
and also
saturday at the farm forum is one of the
most amazing experiences of my life
i mean when you got 20 000 fans of each
school
when that saturday afternoon start
there's nothing like saturday morning
saturday afternoon man this is so cool
did duke or north carolina recruit you
no i wasn't i wasn't a nationwide
recruit uh i was smart remember because
i grew from 5 10 to 6'5 in one year so i
kind of came on the radar late
and i i got recruited by i didn't i
didn't get recruited by big sec schools
like kentucky and
georgia i mean it was pretty much
alabama albert at uab and i made the
best decision ever to go to auburn
it's great to talk to you hope i hope
you're doing well you look good
thank you brother uh things are going
great uh one more weekend and get a get
like five days off before the nba
playoffs start and then this vacation
uh hey so next year remember the super
bowl in uh in arizona next year yeah
i told you are you going to do the show
from the barclay compound well can we
we're trying to figure out
how we can do it you're not going to be
there the whole time there during super
bowl week
like you'll be working wait whoa ho ho
ho i only want you there one day brother
no no no no oh oh my bad oh no oh damn
paulie i thought you said we were doing
the whole week six or seven days at the
chuck mansion no no no no no no one day
one day at the barclaycard first of all
it's not a magic it's a compound no it's
called no no it's called the barkley
center
yeah the barclay center yeah yeah but
yeah but you get one day there dan
you're not gonna do all right
oh all right let me think let me think
about doing i i appreciate the offer but
i thought god we got a week that we can
spend at charles house
yeah yeah yeah no no no nobody can spend
a week at my house you know you can
spend a day at the barca house day
all right well
how many square feet do we have here
i think it's 20
20 000 something like that
when you don't know how many square feet
you have you got too many
well you know
and first of all let's get one thing
straight you're not coming into the main
house
you can either use my drive i got a putt
in green and driving range
and i got a tennis court in my backyard
you're gonna do the show you're gonna do
the show probably from the tennis court
and you when you have to go pee you're
gonna go to the guest house i'm not
letting you in the big house well what's
in the big house that you're worried
about
uh
there's no trophies in there
oh there's a couple trophies in there
you know what the only trophy i got okay
the only trophy i got well i got two
gold medals in there
and i got my mvp those are the only
three medals i never that i have ever
kept in my life
yeah but i can go to michael phelps
house and see all the gold medals i want
i don't care about yours
but listen let me tell you something i
love fab [ __ ] but he don't have no mvp
trophy let me tell you something if you
if you melt all his
all his gol if you melt all his gold
medals they won't be able to make one
mvp trophy don't forget that wow
well
well i can always go to jordan's house
and see you know he's got a few mvps
yeah he got a few mvps now does he does
he keep his stuff out
does he have a display case
i don't know the answer to that question
because i haven't been to the new house
in jupiter okay uh but just for the
record i don't keep my stuff just
sitting out you ever come into a special
room
i don't listen i'll stay in the guest
house
okay that's only when you got to go to
the bathroom you're not staying at
you're not staying anywhere
oh we're not even staying on
on the property
no are you kidding me wait you can come
to the house and do the show and i told
you if you got to go to the bathroom
you're going in the guest house you're
not coming in the big house
how about a guided tour can we do that
with no cameras yeah
okay yes you can do that damn we went
from a whole week there to now
we have a morning and then we don't even
get to stay there hey i tell you what
i'll do dan since i got love for you and
your guys i'll let you do two days oh
god
you know get a hold of the big unit
randy johnson he'll let us stay there
the whole week hey let me tell you
something that's i'm pretty damn sure
you're not going to the big unity's
house
he don't allow anybody around him
he doesn't like anybody he doesn't
like you know what it's so funny i've
had people ask me about randy johnson
for like years i said and randy's always
been great with me personally
and i did like yo man he wasn't very
friendly i said yeah you probably
shouldn't walk up to the big unity
thank you chuck have fun this weekend
all right guys thanks for having me be
safe that's charles barkley we'll take a
break phone calls coming up after this